it's time for our scene in unseen
segment and for that
we turn to fox news contributor raymond
arroyo all right ray
you have a new segment for us tonight
pray tell that is true laura
years ago when the media swooned over
all things obama
you called it the razzle dazzle on your
radio show well
we're now in the age of biden and the
media has defaulted
to its old ways we will chronicle those
shameless reports
all the fawning filler in a new segment
called
marquee malarkey bunch of milwaukee
milwaukee topping tonight's malarkey
laura is a critical
report this critical report from another
network
just into cnn two new arrivals
at the white house champ and major they
are now
in residence we are told the biden's
german shepherds we're told the champ is
enjoying
his new dog bed by the fireplace
major is partial to running on the south
lawn
and if that wasn't newsy enough for you
ingram press secretary jenn
saki released these important tidbits
over the weekend
about the anticipated cat the bidens
promised to bring to dc
get your pencils ready first feline
updates would be greatly appreciated
i'm also wondering about the cat because
the cat is going to dominate
the internet whenever the cat is
announced and wherever that cat is found
i did ask him for my four-year-old niece
soraya who was very curious about what
his favorite ice cream was and his
favorite ice cream is chocolate chip
chocolate chip now laura we're having
fun with this but there's a serious
side to this thing this is all designed
to distract people
from the radical policies being advanced
by the biden administration
despite the rescue dog and the ice cream
chatter biden has already killed 11 000
jobs by canceling the xl pipeline
he's forced biological males into female
sports competitions
and in a few days he's going to pay for
abortions abroad
this is not what the american people
voted for you know it's like that old
joke lawyer
parents don't want peace they want quiet
and that's what the american voter
wanted
instead they're getting this radicalism
and a revision
or return rather to the obama media
playbook
does any of this look familiar to you
we're back at the white house he
exits the limo with two enormous grease
stained
shopping bags full of real food for the
hungry staff
brand new pictures of bo obama looking
like he has the run of the place there
he is
on this rather gray friday
president obama on vacation with his
family in maine
they all stop they get ice cream
there it all is laura it's all there
move over edward r morrow this is
i mean it's it is so it's it's got
they've gone from the obama razzle
dazzle
to the biden marquee malarkey
that's it that's it laura i mean ice
cream dogs
can empire wastes and broadway date
nights be far away i don't think
and we have to apologize because for
weeks we've been saying
that the media were unwilling to cover
hunter biden and when we're wrong
we admit it they proved us wrong indeed
over the weekend president biden and his
family
have frequently gone to catholic mass on
saturdays or sundays
they made a visit there and then on the
way back we understand hunter biden the
president's son
got out of the motorcade and picked up
some bagels at call your mother a jewish
deli
already just in 45 minutes this
afternoon a very
different approach to spending a sunday
from what we saw over the trump years
oh the holy bagel run laura it's amazing
you never know he's under federal
investigation for his foreign dealings
with other governments
no chinese food for ba for the biden
all right speaking of uh biden's mass
attendance i've
got to get your reaction raymond to this
uh times piece by
elizabeth diaz she writes that president
biden perhaps the most religiously
observant
commander in chief in half a century
speaks of how his catholic faith grounds
his life and his policies
now well he speaks about it laura but it
really doesn't
guide his policies i mean this is a man
that the u.s bishops just said
your policies advance moral evils and
that article tries to cut the pope
somehow away from catholic teaching
so that biden looks better the truth is
pope francis has called
abortion an assassination he said that
gender ideology is evil
uh though he does support immigration
and
environmental rights he has not
jettisoned all of catholic doctrine
in the way that joe biden has so this is
a kind of disingenuous faith play
people have to see through this for what
it is all right raymond
the biden bagel run hunter biden
finally gets that insight incisive press
coverage
we've been waiting for thanks so much